alright first off King we just did
something that we've never done on it
what is uh we stopped for a moment so
that Alexis could bring you a chocolate
shake normally normally someone with
diabetes and heart condition I have a
choc the mukla however I've lost weight
and I don't know why they say it comes
with aging I have I try to have a daily
milkshake they're not lose anymore
yeah that's a that's a little call back
to Brooklyn right oh yeah we had
Moulton's to where they put malt in yeah
the candy store there's no candy stores
anymore
there's no case well now they've got
like you know Beverly Hills Super Deluxe
butter you can know I get that candy
yeah put a jukebox and you sit in you
have egg creams yeah let's talk a little
bit about age I guess it's a little
weird to talk about at some level you
are 80 I'll be 85 in November okay so
you can't believe it my father died at
46 I've had every known disease I can't
believe it I can't believe I'm this age
what is it what does it feel like
I mean you you've had a couple heart
attacks in the diabetes a couple of
things and you're still here you're
doing your thing you're out and about
every morning I bump into you half the
time I think that it's the reason I'm
around is that I have a purpose I am
amazed at people who retire as Milton
Berle told me once when I asked somebody
gonna retire and he said to what what
would I do if I get up in the morning
had nothing to do that's terrible so I
have a place to go to follow my
profession that's wonderful if you can
keep that going I'll probably die on the
air
someone asks what would you like you
really want to increase my YouTube views
right now came from yeah what would you
like your obituary to read and I said
oldest man who ever lived
passed away today in his sleep with a
smile on his face but you still get a
kick out of everything I know it so just
real quick tell tell everybody a little
bit about you have these breakfasts with
your old crew well some of them have
passed away the guys are broken but we
have a crew of about five or six we meet
every day at different places and we are
tater tooth David we solve the problems
of the world today we solved Iraq
audience no worries about Iraq the table
solved but mostly through jokes we go
over jokes and we talk about people get
in arguments we talk about Israel we
talk about
hearings who's this what's the senator
doing what's he doing and then we also
discussed Sinatra and old-time musicians
and who's doing what and what in barbra
streisand make our last tour and so we
never know where the discussion is going
and that's the one for him and when you
were gonna have friends from childhood
so a miner passed away but I still have
two others the best thing about it is
I'm not Larry King I'm Larry soccer that
was my birth name and they're very happy
for me but I'm still a but your button
on your shirt no I mean they they don't
treat you like anything different what's
it like as somebody of a certain age now
where you know you just mentioned you've
lost some childhood friends your brother
passed away just last year so months ago
yeah just watching life turned in that
way
that's the Sinatra told me once the
saddest thing about aging is your
friends go before you I didn't want my
brother to die before me he was your
younger brother right yeah
he was 80 I'm yeah he was 80 yeah loss
is hard it's because I don't believe in
afterlife I'm not religious you think
this is it baby that's it
I have never I've interviewed thousands
of people people who said they've seen
death and all this I don't buy it I may
be a little I don't buy it
I just it just makes no sense to me that
Lincoln is up there or that there's
someone up there looking down on me I
went to my grandchildren's their twins a
boy and a girl so they had a bot and a
Bar Mitzvah
and for the first time in ages I read
from the Old Testament that God he's a
worker son of a [ __ ] Jesus did he hate
it what my enemies rule out show me one
good penny my god believe in me above he
was vain in credit he was a Donald Trump
before there was a Donald Trump believe
in me above all of us I am the I can't
believe so when I read that Michael Mele
so I can't buy it
I've interviewed all the great religious
leaders except Pope yeah I've never been
convinced so when you when you sat down
I mean you've sat down with everybody
from the Dalai Lama across the board
with Marie Graham was a friend yeah so
when you've sat down with him even if
you don't believe it did you feel that
some of them were able to get something
out of belief
I believe they believe yeah unless there
are some phonies you know send in $10
and I'll send you a little cross yeah
don't buy any of that
no she's that down with some of those
guys do Oh Jerry Falls as George Burns
once said when he played God it's a
great more great movie great and he
gathers all the religious leaders and he
calls in a Jerry Falwell type and
they've all top Cosi called me in first
goes up to his room sits down and God
says to him why aren't you so shoes so I
never I never bought that part but I
like Billy Graham risk
I'm Billy Graham thought I was very
spiritual and do I believe Billy is with
Jesus no no but Billy believed though he
believed he was going as he had not then
I've feared death he had a fear of being
in a plane that's going down the crash
but he didn't fear death
I feared I'd item on Mike Woody Allen I
don't fear it I just don't want to be
there
I can't bless my wife believes I respect
believers see when I approach an
interview with Billy Graham I respect
him I asked him the best questions I
could ask like why do you need to stay
at the Fontainebleau or Isley I've
called it Lenny Bruce Timm any person
who's got a calling from the Lord to
lead the flock who has more than one
suit while someone has no clothes is a
cop-out and Billy Graham said in today's
world you have to have more than one
soon
you have to travel I I asked him if
Christ right Jesus probably had one pair
of lip balm that crease would work with
Christ would he buy suits and he said
yes and he would go on television that
was the means of communication I mean
that's their answer if he believed it I
respected his belief but I'm not afraid
to ask him any question if when you die
if you believe in Jesus Christ you will
live forever what happens to Jews and he
said well I I don't go into them but
maybe at the moment of their death they
accept Christ that's kind of a cop-out
right there's always sort of another
answer did you ever talk to anybody
either religious or otherwise that you
felt had some sort of special insight
into something well I have this doctor
on who was convinced that he had died
visited what the world of afterlife was
and then his life for Savior he was a
recognized doctor you know what disease
he had I threw it up to a vivid
imagination and he got a best-selling
book out of it people want to believe
you know I wished
that I had faith that I could make it's
called a leap of faith you can't prove
it so it's a leap of faith now we have
faith in a lot of things you get on an
airplane you have the faith that that
airplane company hired a licensed pilot
I but you have some core of beliefs that
you think if you jump out of the 10th
floor of a building you're not gonna
make it so you don't jump the people who
have that faith who go beyond I just
think they've got a great crutch a great
clutch to know you're going somewhere
yeah but at the end do you think it
matters if they if they live a good life
and you live a good life first of all
they're never gonna know yeah if they go
somewhere they were right if they don't
they don't know because they're dead
yeah so they got a good deal going they
really have a good deal I don't have a
I'll be if I've got an afterlife I'll be
shocked yeah or you'll be doing this oh
absolutely
or maybe you'll be playing baseball up
there I'm not that good you know that
good let's talk a little bit about
politics
you mentioned Trump we did about 40
minutes his name didn't even come up
once first time in American conversation
82 people had a conversation for 40
minutes in the name Trump they're not
that's one thing he's done I'll bet you
everyone in America and one time today
said the name Trump everybody everybody
is there anyone else that in the years
that you've been doing this that you saw
just that effect he's the only president
that I've known for 40 years I met the
other presidents some before they became
President Barak Obama George Bush Bill
Clinton but they were in the political
sphere but Trump is the only one that
was my friend before you Trump and I
went to the Super Bowl together yeah can
you talk about our fathers of the year
together that are 1995 yet his kids and
my kids as all of that story we got
trophies I went to see
Marla maples in her Broadway show I went
with Trump I stated his hotels when I
had some minor surgery in New York he
took my wife out to dinner the night
before he caught me at every hotel he
owned put me in a suite at the Plaza
when he owned the plaza but one thing we
always knew about Trump he was a
character and he lied now he he almost
lined by it's snowing out when it wasn't
you know he'd be on my show and say hi
is reading it and it was all about him
but he was a character and it was fun
yeah and he could be very nice and
generous okay
not all those qualities but he was a
character I mean he would call up the
New York Post with a different name and
tell him stories about Donald Trump so
he can get on page six that was his goal
but president pressure are you kidding
anybody any of us who knew him years ago
first he was a moderate it's a central
Democrat supported Hillary Clinton loved
Hillary Clinton thought she was a great
senator he wanted single-payer health
care he didn't care about abortion come
on
evangelicals I don't think Donald ever
read a book but he's but he was a
friendly character to be around a
wonderful guest a lot of fun fly off the
top but President President so what do
you make about what happened like I have
no idea where Hillary was a bad
candidate a wonderful person I know
Hillary very well great sense of humor
sad I don't know what if she didn't go
to Wisconsin did you get a different
Hillary when you went into her interview
her publicly this is what a lot of her
is is that she's very friendly and open
one-on-one she's good yeah front of an
audience she's not she's not a good if
she's running for something now if I
went to Yom Kippur service where she was
the speaker she was terrific she wasn't
running for anything she was a senator
from New York damn good senator she ran
a horrendous campaign and she was not a
good
I thought she won the debates but it
almost didn't matter Trump became well
Trump got elected with that first
question in the first Republican debate
when he was asked about women and did he
ever called women pigs that he said only
Rosie O'Donnell and he sat in the middle
of all the Republicans why did they seat
him in the middle
he was just for on one side for Nia did
you really think of them from that
moment that I thought he would ignite
something but I thought he was dead when
he said that thing about McCain isn't a
hero
certainly when he got off the bus with
Billy Bush I thought that was over
but his base doesn't care if
evangelicals can put aside his personal
life he'll never lose them he'll never
say it's always I never lived in weird
at times I mean this is the weirdest
time to know every day yeah there's a
story does this truly enjoy yours does
this right now feel like a truly truly
unique time because people ask me that
all the club events I do and I think the
answer is yes although you always think
it when you're living it but of course
these respective do you believe that
somebody said one day to see what
Lincoln said yesterday to hear what
Roosevelt did last night
did you see the speech that Quartermaine
today you win was that weird no they
didn't do weird things
they were president yeah I remember I
was in the White House interviewing
George Bush from Barbara Bush said to me
Larry suspenders in the White House if
she was in the White House's this place
is now I wonder what it's like in there
Kerry the guy writes the op-ed piece in
The New York Times my god the wood wood
book fascinating book we're living in
those times and wouldn't believe it but
I can see as you talk about it there's a
glimmer in your eye like there's
something exciting about this do you
think that that's in a weird way the
good part of this even if it's kind of
helter skelter now and I'm glad I'm not
on
you know I wouldn't want to be doing
panels every day and Trump all the time
I don't want to do it
yeah that's not the whole world Trump's
not the whole world he thinks he's the
huh how important do you think politics
actually is because I think now there's
maybe what I'm realizing now is that
this is really about culture what we're
fighting right now this this battle that
seems to be in points about culture it's
about what do we really care about what
do we like not just about the ins and
outs and machinations no I think too
much of America is still prejudiced
against Latinos blacks that still runs
through a lot of us in my opinion people
voting against their own self-interest
you know let's I want to face it with
something Obamacare is working for a lot
of people you don't hear many complaints
about people who are under it and
getting good medical care I'm not sure
that I'll ever do away with it no no
it's just those those kind of facts are
so it bothers me when I see that why we
still have prejudice in America and
appeal to it I mean Trump even his
defendant would say he appeals to it
what do we need we need a war do you
think do you think that's a play by him
I mean for all the years you knew him
did you think he was racist or that this
is I never thought he was racist I think
he was opportunity he was he took
advantage of a situation so we used to
say he wasn't smart
he wasn't book smart I bet at school he
got a gentleman see the big influences
in his life were Roy Cohn who I knew
very well yeah and his father and they
were bad influences I mean Roy Cohn was
I I liked them causing this peculiar
yeah but he was waiting for the people
that don't know who rikon is he was a
bad guy he was part of the McCarthy era
Angels in America had he played a part
in that play
and he was affected by that so I never I
never thought he was a racist but his
narcissism was beyond belief I in every
other sentence I did this I did that I'm
the greatest president we've ever had
coffee just save it how could you say
that so if you were sitting down with
him I would say Donald why I spoke to
him every day during the camp and not
every day once a week during the
campaign he knew I was voting for
Hillary but we were friends and he would
call me what do you think it is I'm
doing is what you think about I got this
what do you think it is something I'm
gonna do an interview with the New York
Times you know the guy should I do this
and then when he was elected I never
heard from him again
I would heard do you think we can get
out of this polarization that we seem to
be in so if we're in this unique time
right now in crazy time how's it gonna
change you know we don't have a
forcefully - it might be Bloomberg to
lead us we need someone to lead us all
we need Gary Cooper maybe George Clooney
in the modern society I'm not kidding
George Clooney a bright and he is bright
George Clooney will be very popular
women's vote smart as a whip
what does that tell you though if we
need to go to celebrities you think
maybe we're just in there in this real
news this is that's the Internet
that's the world we live in yeah yeah I
like George oh uh I vote for ya what do
you think we can get out of this this
well they say America always comes
through everything George will who's
become very anti Trump believes we can
find a way again America's a way of
finding a way
I hope so I hope I'm around to see it
but right now you know when ah in my
early I could name every senator 10 10
20 years ago every sound yeah and guy
Orrin Hatch and Ted Kennedy were great
friends sponsored bills together hatch
did his eulogy
mmm-hmm that that wouldn't exist today
that would today the the thing is so bad
when Obama nominated his guy for the
Supreme Court I shouldn't forget his
name and they never brought it up now
course it's Nick will get it will get it
or not when it when when we nominate
people like that who was pretty much
middle of the road
Oh Garland America Merrick garland yeah
if I woulda Democrats now and they take
the Senate I will hold up any
appointment yeah until they can have a
president and first person out a point
would be Merrick garland who deserved to
be on that Court yeah so this is just
both of them playing politics to dance
but will we have a chance i I don't see
it coming you know when Merrick garland
was nominated for excel orrin hatch
before he knew they would delay it said
he's a great man mm-hmm and then it
becomes party over country party over
country said well I you think it's gonna
change I think that the outrage machine
that we're running on right now I think
it can only last for so long so I think
it could you know either blow up into
something much worse and I don't even
know what I mean by that but I think
things would actually get much worse and
some of this would actually spill over
into violence or what my hope is and I
think this is the more realistic option
is that the outrage will start running
out of steam like a car running out of
gas and that from that somebody whether
maybe it's your Cloney or its whoever
else it is that just saw a decent human
being
a Bloomberg or something else will come
back and decency will be appreciated
because I don't think this outrage thing
can run forever it's too it's too
mentally exhausting it's too it's
physically there's a decent man I've
known for years is Joe Biden nobody
dislikes some wonderful father that
there was a great senator great vice
president if he were a little younger
can you imagine he'd be what 82 or
something because she can't dislike him
you want to be VP no I couldn't take the
cut and pay alright let's let's finish
up with some some big picture it's a big
picture stuff looking back is there
anything you would have done differently
career when I got married as much I
would have gone national sooner I had
the talent but I was a big fish in a
smaller pond in Miami and I like that
I'd radio television column and the
Miami Herald
you know everybody knew me in Miami I
never sent a tape to New York right I
should have I would have liked to gone
national sooner just just to have more
success earlier did appeal more people
of course I had something I knew I was
good I know I was good at what I did and
I I didn't really get well-known so my
fifties and I think it could happen in
the 30s I'm not any better than I was in
the 30s I'm not better today than I was
when I was in my late 20s I was also I
always was curious I always let my ego
at the door
or was there short questions always got
really interested in the guests that
never changed sometimes someone will
play me a tape that they had for 30
years ago still me yeah I'm still
they're still asking questions I think
the first time I interviewed you I asked
you something about the ego component
relative to interviewing and your answer
I loved it and I've really tried to
incorporate it in what I do which is you
said the show was called Larry King
tonight my ego is already stroked I'll
be there tomorrow my model it's a good
model David could be your model
could be anybody's model if Donald Trump
had this model we would be a better
country this is my model I never learned
anything when I was talking think about
it I never learned anything when I was
talking now I may impart things to
people
I may be some knowledge but I haven't
learnt anything when I'm talking it
feels like a privilege in a way right
when you have somebody great across from
you and you get damn like this I'm
telling you this hour of my life is a
privilege oh to be on a reuben report to
be part of what by the way senses a
report do I get a grade you will be
graded at the Oh trust me the YouTube
commenters they're gonna get you to
comment so they're gonna see I don't
have the wool with all the how do you do
must be Larry King that is the last
thing I want to impart on you all right
final question here we go
what's it all about I've asked you this
I've asked you some version of this many
time every day what's it about my friend
what's it all about and what does it all
mean what does it mean a hundred years
from today who's gonna care john
lowenstein once hit a grand slam home
run for the Orioles to beat the Yankees
and it what crowd went crazy
someone said John how does it feel and
he said a hundred million Chinese don't
give a damn what does it all mean the
answer is I don't know all right my
friend well despite the fact that you
did not wear suspenders today I did not
I want them to be totally casual with
you this true this is what it's about
what I what we just did for the last
hour thank you baby thank you my
pleasure and thank you for the milkshake
all right you guys can check out Larry
on aura TV and follow them on Twitter at
Kings things
[Music]